До схід сонця. Маріуполь ще спить,
а тут, на узбережжі Азовського моря,
в кооперативі "Ялик " уже прокинулися.
Як тут кажуть, разом із чайками.
А можливо, й раніше.
- Готовность намбер ван.
Рибаку Леоніду Болдишору 60 років.
Він на пенсії, як і більшість членів кооперативу.
Це спільнота затятих рибалок, чиє життя
дуже змінила війна на Донбасі та анексія Криму.
За останні п’ять років заходи безпеки в Азовському морі і на узбережжі
суттєво посилили українські прикордонники.
Вільно пересуватися морем заборонено.
Дозволено рибалити лише вдень: виходити на світанку,
а за годину до заходу сонця повертатися.
- Вночі рибалити не можна, не можна ловити сітками.
Можна на вудку, три гачки.
У рибалок свої таємниці.
Трохи плюнув - і щось та буде.
Леонід помітно нервується.
Поки він розмовляє з нами, його колеги займають найбільш рибні місця.
Адже рибалкам кооперативу прикордонники
дозволяють виходити в море лише на 300 метрів
від узбережжя.
- Гудбай, Америка!
За рибалками в морістежитиме береговий матрос Сергій.
В Азовському морі через війну на Сході України та анексію Криму
взагалі рибалити без дозволу прикордонників заборонено.
Кожен вихід в море, кількість людей на борту, мету -
все це треба узгоджувати.
- Мають прикордонники знати, хто в море виходить,
як, коли. Щохвилинно. Ось журнал.
Можете подивитися. Хто і які номери човнів.
А там, у морі, вже прикордонний катер їх перевіряє.
Хто в човні? Якщо дві людини заявлено, то
має бути в човні дві. Якщо одна людина, то одна.
Відповідно до Договору про використання Азовського моря
та Керченської протоки, який Україна та Росія
уклали наприкінці 2003 року, відкритими водами
вільно користуються кораблі обох держав.
До анексії Криму й початку війни на Донбасі у морі
вільно ходили потужні риболовецькі катери й судна.
Утім, із 2014 року українські прикордонники
дедалі жорсткіше контролють морський кордон.
Це фактично не відрізняється від перевірок
на блокпостах біля лінії розмежування.
У морі можна також натрапити на додаткові перевірки.
І не лише з боку українських, а  ще й російських
прикордонників, розповідають у Держрибагентстві.
- Суднам, які проводять промисел у відкритій частині Азова…
Там, звичайно, є проблемав тому, що вилов обмежений.
Вони не можуть наблизитися до Керченської затоки.
Не можуть вести промисел камси в цих районах.
Через конфліктну ситуацію вони бояться втратити майно.
Як на практиці діють російські обмеження для українських рибалок,
знімальна група DW не мала можливості побачити на власні очі,
перебуваючи на підконтрольній Києву території.
Українські промислові риболови розповідають, що,
аби не ризикувати, зменшили кількість виходів туди,
де можна натрапити на російських прикордонників.
І все це позначається на вилові.
- Тюлька не ловиться. Медузи багато.
Обмеження риболовлі відчули на собі і спеціалізовані магазини.
Рибалки сюди навідуються нечасто.
А в городян, що хочуть купити рибу на ринку, -
невеликий вибір саме свіжовиловленої риби з Азовського моря.
Частіше ось такі бички.
- Усенайсвіжіше. По очах подивіться. По зябрах.
Є морожені бички.
Після п'яти годин риболовлі Леонід повертається ось із чим.
- Ой, сьогодні дуже невдало.
- Ну, що молодь? Показати улов?
- Покажіть!
- Ну ось, норму зробив.3 кг.
- Ура!
Це на уху бабці, яка любить смажених бичків, і її котам, каже Леонід.
Як затятий рибалка, він мріє про повернення часів,
коли він привозив не лише бичків, а й того ж судака, пеленгаса.
Чоловік розуміє, що передусім через війну
"велика риболовля" поки неможлива.
Тож дедалі більше рибалок із цього кооперативу Маріуполя,
як вони іронічно кажуть, перепрофілюються на рибоїдів.